so what's the difference between a type  scale and a type system a type scale is  a group of type sizes that work well  together because they increase and  decrease in the same proportion so like  a simple type scale  is to start with a reasonable paragraph  size and then double it every time you  bump up in the hierarchy so for example  if you start at 16 pixels then the next  level up would be 32 and then 64 and so  on and so forth and the scale is  literally all about the proportions  between the different sizes and why they  work well together type system is how  you choose to use those different sizes  within your scale you know how big your  primary headings are versus your caption  text or how big your paragraphs are  versus your sub headers the system is  crucial to establish really early in the  design exploration process if you want  to learn more about type systems type  scales check out our type 1 course it's  linked in the description below